cette télé n'a pas de câble elle
fonctionne sur batterie vous pouvez la
prendre dans votre main vous balader
avec alors l'idée c'est pas de se
balader avec une télé mais c'est
l'innovation que tu présentes une boîte
américaine qui s'appelle display c'est
en fait ce qu'ils veulent montrer ici
c'est que on peut avoir de la modularité
on va le poser sur un plexi on peut
faire pas mal de choses sans câble si
vous n'avez pas la possibilité de
brancher quelque chose sur le secteur et
bien vous pouvez avoir votre télé alors
l'idée en plus ici c'est qu'il y a aucun
port pas de port HDMI pas de port USB
rien du tout juste le moniteur vous avez
un peu moins de 2 heures d'autonomie
c'est vraiment plus à usage
professionnel et on peut même venir
combiner plusieurs télés pour faire un
sol et même grand affichage alors ici
nous propose différentes tailles on a du
55 pouces on a du 110 pouces on a du 220
pouces avec de la résolution jusqu'à 16
cartes ce qui vous dit on vient tout
combiner je pense que c'est pour ça
l'idée est assez marrante je sais pas
combien que ce soit assez dingue on vit
en plus streamer du contenu directement
là why notch parce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous trouvez l'innovation
marrante est-ce qu'elle a un sens
dites-le-moi dans les commentaires